we've talked before about this
disgusting Republican congressman Matt
Gaetz from Florida he is a brown-nosing
Trump sycophants of the highest order
real piece of work
one of the most pro-gun people in the
House of Representatives he tried to get
Robert Muller recused from the
investigation that Muller was running
that didn't work he supports Trump's tax
cuts as a matter of economics he
disagrees with the science on climate
change he's been arrested from drunk for
drunk driving on the personal side so
this guy's a real piece of work and
someone that is truly an enemy to
everything that someone who cares about
the United States of America should be
advocating for he should be voted out
ASAP regardless of what he did yesterday
but that gets us to what he did
yesterday Matt Gaetz tweeted on the eve
of Michael Cohen's absolutely bombshell
testimony today about Donald Trump hey
Michael Cohen do your wife and
father-in-law know about your
girlfriends maybe tonight would be a
good time for that chat I wonder if
she'll remain faithful when you're in
prison she's about to learn a lot now
gates has since deleted the suite after
Nancy Pelosi knocked him around verbally
proverbially speaking so to speak and it
with words not physically but we were
able to obtain the tweet anyway thanks
to the magic of the internet and the
obvious interpretation of what Matt
Gaetz is saying here is Michael Cohen
and Matt gates should talk tonight
meaning last night before Cohen
testifies unless Cohen wants information
released about I guess girlfriends or
mistresses to his wife and father-in-law
so this is a threat this is a threat of
blackmail and it appears to be illegal
because there's this thing in the 18 USC
subsection 1512 B specifically not a but
B which prohibits tampering with
witnesses to official proceedings
which is exactly what Michael Cohen is
today as he testifies before the House
Committee if we put up section 1512 B of
this US law a code of justice it says
whoever knowingly uses intimidation
threatens or corruptly persuades another
person or attempts to do so or engages
in misleading conduct toward another
person that means whether the threats of
exposing mistresses are real or not if
the intent is to influence delay or
prevent the testimony of any person in
an official proceeding or to cause or
induce any person to withhold testimony
or withhold a record or a document from
an official proceeding or to alter
destroy mutilate or conceal an object
with intent to impair the object's
integrity or availability for use in a
public proceeding this would all be
against the law all eyes would as sub
subsection 3 or portion 3 I don't know
even how to call these nested provisions
if the idea is to hinder delay or
prevent the communication to law
enforcement officers or judges of the
u.s. relating to the commission or
possible Commission of federal offenses
like the things Cohen his alleging Trump
did that person shall be fined under
this title or imprisoned not more than
20 years or both now of course Matt
Gaetz
is not going to be imprisoned for this
he is not going to be fined for this but
there is the significant possibility
that there will be a House Ethics
investigation into it but this is pretty
clear
it totally imploded and gates his face
he first responded he's not tampering
with witnesses by saying this he's
testing witnesses he's testing I claimed
Michael Cohen's character and veracity
of his claims by threatening him with
the revelation of girlfriends of his to
his wife and father-in-law now as I
mentioned Gates later deleted the tweet
he realized it was a disastrous idea
after Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of the
House completely crushed him
oriT she put out a statement saying I
encourage all members to be mindful that
comments made on social media or in the
press can adversely affect the ability
of House committees to obtain the
truthful and complete information
necessary to fulfill their duties and
Matt Gaetz not long after that quoted
Nancy Pelosi's tweet and said Speaker I
want to get to the truth too while it is
important to create context around the
testimony of liars like Michael Cohen it
was not my intent to threaten as some
believe I did I'm deleting the tweet and
I should have chosen words that better
showed my intent I'm sorry
oh no he he chose words that very
precisely indicated what his intent was
his intent was to dissuade Michael Cohen
from giving the testimony that he gave
today on the basis that Gates would
expose alleged affairs girlfriends of
Michael Cohen's to Michael Cohen's
family and of course he's trying to save
face here while deleting this total
train wreck of a tweet there's a couple
of things here I also mentioned that
Gates is unlikely to face consequences
here in general but there's a more
important reason why it gates is
unlikely to face consequences Trump has
done much worse witness intimidation and
tampering on Twitter if you go after
gates for this you sort of have to go
after Trump too or it will expose that
he's getting special treatment and
getting away with it since what Donald
Trump has done in terms of witness
intimidation and witness tampering is
way worse way worse than what Matt Gaetz
attempted to do here the other thing is
do we really believe that Matt Gaetz
came up with this all by himself or is
it more likely that this threat from
gates is actually a threat from Trump
via proxy because after all that's what
Trump is known for and I spoke to some
lawyers this morning who said if they
look not at not if they were
high-powered elected officials are
involved in something like this but if
they just had a regular client a Joe
Schmo who went on Twitter after do
this they would be advising them you
should be prepared to be arrested by
police period because this is so far
over the line this is so far beyond the
pale
but of course with Republican
congressman who are friends and
surrogates of Donald Trump and some
implicit or explicit way he deleted the
tweet what else can we do he also
apologized to Nancy Pelosi and said that
his choice of words was wrong conduct
completely unbecoming an elected
official in a so-called distinguished
gentlemen of the House of
Representatives in the midst of 20
scandals a week there will probably be
no consequences whatsoever but if we're
lucky maybe we'll get at least some kind
of investigation into this that will if
nothing else prevent gates from doing
even Dumber things while that
investigation is going on make sure
you're following the show on Instagram
at David Pakman show we will take a
break part two of my interview with Cass
Sunstein is coming up next
today's show is made possible in part by
son basket giving everybody in our
audience 60% off their first box when
you go to get son basket calms slash
Pakman you'll get six dinners delivered
to your door for just twenty eight
dollars son basket is a meal kit service
that brings fresh ingredients for ready
to cook recipes to your home but they
are not like some of the other companies
that you might have heard about because
what makes son basket different is their
commitment to sustainability which I
know is really important to lots of
people in our audience organic
ingredients USDA certified antibiotic
hormone free meats as well as an ability
to accommodate just about any type of
diet if you are low carb if you are
gluten-free if you are paleo vegetarian
vegan pescetarian Mediterranean Sun
basket has you covered or even if you're
not sticking to a particular type of
diet Sun basket has a lot of great plans
to choose from
just pick a meal plan choose how many
recipes you want per week you can even
choose which recipes you want before you
get them so that you know you're getting
meals you'll enjoy and the list of
recipes changes
every week you can also choose when the
meals show up at your home which is
really useful for me in particular you
can even skip weeks if you need to
everything that needs to stay cold stays
cold everything stays totally fresh all
the ingredients are pre measured which
makes everything really easy for you and
all of their packaging is recyclable and
compostable which I especially love
start getting sustainable delicious
healthy organic meals sent right to your
home and get a 60 percent discount off
your first week of meals just by going
to get Sun basket dot-com slash Pakman
you'll get six dinners delivered to your
door for just 28 bucks I've put the link
right underneath this video